it's time for drew's news come shake
your news hips and our good news hula
and with me at the desk is a man who had
his first hula right here ross matthews
yes
that's right hi rossy
we've
by the way tell everybody what you said
when you walked out i said oh good more
carbs thank you
all right well first up
if you're about to walk down that aisle
but you're agonizing over crafting that
perfect wedding speech we've got a
solution
metro reports that you can now hire a
ghostwriter for your wedding
you've already got a florist and a
caterer so why not a word smith the
company is called speechy and they write
personalized speeches for brides grooms
best men's wacky aunts you name it and
they really do a deep dive to make these
personal they interview you beforehand
and craft something unique specific and
cliche free for anyone who thinks this
is unromantic the company says the
grooms get in touch months in advance
because they just want to get it right
well let me ask you out of the gate
um because you're about to get married
how would you feel if you i know
i know
how would you feel if wellington
resourced with speechy
okay let's talk about it
so i have mixed emotions about this
topic one i'm like no and then i'm like
wait a second you know you think about
it as a skill set you know i'm good at
certain things you know but algebra i'm
not good at roofing i'm not good at so i
would hire someone to roof my house for
me so if you don't have the particular
skill set of writing your intentions and
your thoughts down maybe this would work
for you that being said wellington my
fiance
don't you dare
i would rather my partner came out and
mumbled their way through their feelings
and i'm not good at this but this is
what you mean to me and mess it up and
have it kind of be silly than to have it
be perfect and written by some yoo-hoo
you know what i'm saying so don't try it
but if you need it i mean i guess good
for you okay so you're halves he have z
i don't want to be but i kind of am i
don't want to judge anybody else but uh
uh-uh
okay ross your story all right next up
we've got a style trend you're gonna see
everywhere this season
in style reports this spring it's all
about the high low look we're talking
short in the front and long in the rear
it's like a mullet skirt
it's it's shirts with trains and skirts
with trains it's the perfect look for
anyone who suffers from a chronically
chilly booty or just wants to try a tail
um look at this it's basically like a um
butt flap it's a booty be gone so i
think this trend is taking off because
it's a culture we're sort of obsessed
with booties so this feels like so
demure yeah well think it started with
like a jlo and a kim k we all wanted
that big booty so if you didn't have it
you're like insecure yeah are you guys
doing this though are you wearing the
long trend i actually have a couple
shirts i think it's kind of cute with a
jean hands up who thinks that this is
fashionable and cool
that the the trains
who thinks it looks like a hot mistake
you don't like it
these cuts are you know when something
is kind of on the bias and it's sort of
like t length in the back a little
shorter than the front but it's like
kind of an illusion you're like oh it it
this just looks like it does look like
mud flaps yeah it kind of like oh the
one on the semi right yeah with the
naked girl yes which i love i love those
i used to have earrings of her um this
this this is not what i will be wearing
to your wedding raw oh okay wait can i
go back you used to have earrings of the
mud flap with the girl on it hell yes
you know what i like about you
you're so weird
it's funny because it's true
[Music]